[Music]
there goes my toothpaste I am tired of
this go keep living on this frozen
festive Alec
[Music]
we're gonna need a bigger slingshot
[Music]
[Music]
it could have happened at anybody but it
didn't it happened us
[Applause]
a new band is gonna be something
nobody's ever seen before
oh my god those are my pants but they
look so much better on me we got it run
away a cheap plumber
an old man let's just play it calmer
bansemer they say you're gonna be a rock
star
what do you think
[Music]
holy [ __ ] we want to knock people on
their asses then we've gotta give him a
show I'm talking like a stadium show in
the club's a fans that dying for some
anarchy so let's give it to him
[Music]
I work for Elektra Records you guys like
a record you
[Music]
[Applause]
I had managed the scorpions Bon Jovi
skid-row
kiss but I have never been through what
motley crew put me
I am sick and tired of not having any
fun everything's upside-down and
flip-floppy motley crue no strangers to
controversies Neal was charged with
vehicular manslaughter tommy lee and
heather locklear have separated it's a
degenerative bone disease nikki sixx has
overdosed I know it's like amazing but I
believe in us
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
I read about you in the paper last
mostly guess I don't really know how to
though I don't know yo Billy the Kid
my father's beating my mother today
lately with me while he'll take us with
you
how long even sheriff have two weeks
do not feel special when they start
writing about she means you're already
dead all of a sudden I'm enemy number
one there are families in this town hurt
by this man's crimes come again
[Music]
you think she could run for me that one
has to tie style I think that one of
life's partialities what more Stephanie
will be your last
you really think I'm like you
I know it is my lucky day wonderful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you think I do you hurt one hair
on his head I'm taking my nephew with me
every single one of these peoples gonna
tell the tale now you ran they know it's
not true doesn't matter what's true it
matters the story they tell when you're
gone
[Music]
I mean bullets you got in your 16 I
think it might be good to have a doctor
look at you sometime might be good to
have doctor with you sometime
ain't got no bullet in me cuz I was
covertly
you may have heard there was prison
break
it was Bonnie incline governor this has
to end they've committed dozens of armed
robberies and several cold-blooded
murders what are you planning to do
about Bonnie and Clyde we will capture
them fret that down and underline it
twice there's only one man who can take
them down I'll come back hey you got a
room for one more night impact
Judas Priest get in
this is 1934 gangsters submachine guns
and you put Cowboys on bun in five Texas
Rangers forgive me Father for I have
seen this is a highly coordinated
operation so much pain and suffering
roadblocks air surveillance your time
has passed cowboy what the hell is the
world coming to weeks to be and have
talent to get published now all you got
to do is shoot she used her foot to turn
him over so he could see what was about
to happen
pack sweet
[Music]
this has gone far enough when I take
them down we're a fine idea
[Music]
who are you Phyllis those were the bad
guys
come to the wrong place mister around
here cloud is keen buddy
ride my became but I'm a Texas Ranger
you little [ __ ] now it didn't see me
magic swirls all around us it is in the
air that we breathe do not be so naive
as to think we are the only ones who can
harness its power
[Music]
congratulations on your acceptance to
Belgrave University we have a question
what do you know about their medical are
at the Blue Rose everyone knows the
orders fake news you're about to start
the biggest adventure of your lives
what is it appears you've been sullen we
hate the call yes
they expecting great things from you
welcome to the order I'm gonna teach you
how to use magic properly a tutor you
got stuck with me for some reason just
lucky I guess there is a creature out
there that is tearing apart our recruits
this is being most powerful incantation
ever created what is it - anything is
possible if you do something people are
gonna die
we will build a world like you've never
seen
this is what you signed up for nothing
all magic has a cause if you don't pay
the price things would go wrong
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]